part of me wishes that um
Elon went into nuclear fusion versus
Twitter
part of me or somebody somebody like Eli
you know we need to
gosh I wish there were more more elons
in the world and yeah I Lan sees it as
like uh this is a political battle that
needed to be fought and again like you
know I always ask the question of
whenever I disagree with him I remind
myself that he's a billionaire and I'm
not so uh you know maybe he's got
something figured out that I don't or
maybe he doesn't to have some
humility but at the same time me as a
person who happens to know him I find
myself in that same position
sometimes even billionaires need friends
who disagree and help them grow
and that's a difficult that's a
difficult reality and it must be so hard
it must be so hard to meet people
once you get to that point where Fame
power money everybody's sucking up to
you see I love not having like I
don't have man you don't like like
trust me there's nothing I can give you
there's nothing worth taking for me you
know yeah it takes a really special
human being when you have power when you
have Fame when you have money to still
think from first principles not like all
the Adoration you get towards you all
the admiration all the people saying yes
yes and all the hate too and the hates
the hate makes you want to go to the yes
people because they they hate to exhaust
you and they kind of hate that elon's
gotten from the left is pretty intense
and so that of course drives them right
and
loses balance and um but it keeps this
absolutely fake like
psyop political divide alive so that the
one percent can keep power like yeah
I wish would be less divided because it
is giving power it gives power to the
ultra powerful
the rich get richer